So the term fake news has been very much weaponized
by the current administration. And very often
when they say that
thing is fake news, it's not actually fake
news. It's just news they don't like or news
that paints the administration in a negative
light. But we have some actual fake news that
was repeated and parroted by the administration
and even some right wing media outlets that
turned out to be as the name actually suggests
completely and totally false. And it relates
to an agreement or more specifically pieces
of an agreement that supposedly are part of,
um, a, a Mexican agreement that Donald Trump
has reached. And before I even tell you what
was said and what's true and what's not true,
one of the worst things that a country can
do, geo politically is to make itself not
trustworthy when other countries can't trust
you in the big picture sense. I'm not talking
about intelligence gathering and the reality
that, um, uh, many countries have, you know,
intelligence operatives within a country that
are clandestine.
I'm not talking about that. I'm saying when
other countries can't trust you to even stick
to the deals that you make with them, can't
trust you to simply tell the truth about what
you've agreed to do with them. You become
toxic on the world stage. And that's what
Donald Trump has become. One big example being
the Iran deal, President Obama, uh, forged
a forward with the Iran deal, the Iran nuclear
deal. Donald Trump didn't like it, but when
Donald Trump took over as president, Iran
had not violated any elements of the Iran
deal. So when Donald Trump comes in and says,
I never liked that deal, we're just backing
out of it immediately. The United States loses
credibility, not just with Iran, which may
be many Americans don't care about, but with
the entire world community in terms of being
a country that other countries can have the
confidence, we'll stick to agreements that
they sign even when the next guy or gal is
in the White House.
So that was a horrible example of the ways
in which the Trump administration simply cannot
be trusted. But now we have something that's
also horrible, which is that it appears that
Donald Trump completely made up elements,
uh, that supposedly had been reached as part
of the deal with Mexico. All meant to show
how smart and strong and a great negotiator
Donald Trump is. Think back to a couple of
weeks ago when Donald Trump announced on Twitter
those absurd tariffs on Mexico, which would
make things more expensive for everyday Americans.
And Trump said at the time the goal of those
tariffs with, to get Mexico to do what he
wants on immigration. Finally, stop people
from coming to the United States, from Mexico
illegally, including from points further south
of Mexico. Uh, and Donald Trump said that
the tariffs were meant to sort of push Mexico
into compliance with what Donald Trump wants,
except that if the tariffs actually succeeded
in hurting Mexico, it would cause more people
to want to come to the United States, which
is exactly the opposite of what Donald Trump
claimed that he wanted.
So we explained how those tariffs made no
sense. Three days ago, Donald Trump announces
he's made a big deal with Mexico. Trump won.
Trump was right, his threat of tariffs worked.
And Mexico has agreed to do all the stuff
that Donald Trump wants them to do, except
it appears that Donald Trump was lying at
least about part of it. Checkout all of the
things that Donald Trump tweeted about this,
uh, many of which Mexican Foreign Secretary
Marcello abroad now says are not true. Donald
Trump tweeted, quote, Mexico has agreed to
immediately begin buying large quantities
of agricultural product from our crate. Patriot
farmers, Mexico says, not true. The Mexican
Foreign Secretary. We do not have a specific
agreement on products of that nature. Period.
Full Stop. Trump's line. Monday, Donald Trump
claimed it was all done because of the tariffs
and because of the relationship that we have
with Mexico also completely untrue.
Uh, it appears as though according to the
Mexican foreign secretary, only two actions
were agreed upon on Friday. Publicly. There's
nothing else. And one of those was actually
already previously agreed to and isn't even
a new thing. It's not clear that Donald Trump
knows that the Mexican Foreign Secretary Marcello
abroad saying, quote, there is no other thing
beyond what I have just explained. They wanted
something else totally different to be signed,
but that is what there is here. There is no
other thing referring to Donald Trump's sort
of implication that there are unwritten elements
of this deal as well. The next few Mexican
authorities saying, this is it. There are
two things that are part of this deal. Number
one, uh, a commitment from Mexico to deploy.
It's national guard to the country, southern
border with Guatemala. Now, it's hilarious
that that's even considered an accomplishment
by Trump because Mexico already had agreed
to do that before Donald Trump even started
the tariff threat.
Understand that that's something Mexico had
already agreed to do. Number two, that's part
of this deal is that Mexico will now publicly
support the expansion of a program where some
asylum seekers will go back to Mexico while
their cases are being adjudicated or processed
by the American immigration system. That has
already been going on quietly. Okay? Understand
that 11,000 Mexicans have already gone back
to Mexico under this, uh, um, action or agreement
by Mexico. Mexico is now just publicly going
to support the expansion of that program.
So understand the absurdity of what's going
on here publicly. Donald Trump claims that
there are things in the deal which just aren't
part of the deal. He gets publicly debunked
by Mexican officials. When we look at what's
actually in the deal, there are two things
in the deal, one of which was already previously
announced. It's not clear.
Trump knows that and thinks that might actually
be a bonafide accomplishment. The other is
something that Mexico has already quietly
been doing, but now they are going to publicly
support expanding. This is total fake news.
This is how it all develops and it's really
important to understand the process. Trump
tweets about it, the Trump sycophants and
followers go crazy promoting it and claiming
victory on the basis of Donald Trump's tweets.
And then we find out, oh, Mexico says like
almost none of that stuff is true and the
stuff that is true isn't new. So media outlets
go to the White House for comment. They say,
Trump tweeted this and here's what the Mexican
authorities say and here's what the records
say that we've been able to find and the White
House simply doesn't comment. And meanwhile
most Trump is, we'll never hear about the
fact that this was fake and concocted.
It remains the truth in the minds of Trumpists
that Donald Trump has actually accomplished
this when he has not. It's sad, but it's dangerous.
It's weaponized ignorance. It's weaponized
low information and on the world stage it
makes us look extraordinarily childish and
like we can't be trusted, which under Donald
Trump we actually can't be trusted. And that's
the most important takeaway in terms of the
effect of this stuff. On geopolitics, the
short term I guess will be resolved. Like
eventually there will be some seeing eye to
eye between the u s and Mexico about what
is and isn't in the deal. And it'll probably
look more like what Mexico thinks is in the
deal than what Donald Trump thinks or claims
is in the deal. But the irreversible or at
least a very difficult to reverse problem
that's caused here, uh, is the national embarrassment
that is the United States seen as dishonest,
the United States not being seen as even a
remotely reliable negotiating partner.
That is a PR been precipitated significantly
under the current president.